cuando un niño comienza en el deporte lo
hace por un sueño
los niños no piensan en el prestigio en
la fama los niños piensan y tienen un
sueño el mío por ejemplo era ser
gimnasta
recuerdo que el año 92 la televisión
abierta transmitía los juegos olímpicos
de barcelona la pantalla era un gimnasta
como él
con un físico increíble dando vueltas en
la barra fija usted sabe en ese fierro
donde se sueltan se agarran se toman
de repente se desmonta el aparato cae no
mueve un músculo separa una arena con
10.000 personas lo aplauden y en ese
momento fue cuando dije quiero estar ahí
y le dije a mi madre quiero ser gimnasta
si mezclamos esa idea que yo tenía ese
sueño cuando era muy pequeño con el
tremendo déficit de atención al que
tenía
que lo demostraba haciendo tremendas
travesuras con mi hermana que estoy hoy
en día en la mañana aquí para mi madre
no fue tan difícil apoyarme me llevo un
club deportivo el club huachipato inició
este sueño de crearse gimnasta
para mí inició un sueño para ella fue
simplemente pagar para que mi energía
bajaron un poco
cuando comienza en el deporte todo parte
como un juego estaba en provincia
entrenas algo así como 23 horas a la
semana
y es con mucha dificultad no hay
implementación no hay recursos los papás
financian todo es complicado pero con
algo de disciplina
con un poquito un poquito de trabajo
logra ir a un campeonato nacional y es
ahí cuando algunos nos pica el bichito
de ser profesional porque te enfrentas a
los grandes club de santiago a los
tremendos gimnastas que hay hoy en día y
que habían en ese tiempo y quiere ser
profesional pero en chile es súper
difícil hacer deporte es muy difícil más
allá de que no hay infraestructura en
esos años de que no hay un sistema que
provoque y que haga que existan
deportistas de alto rendimiento no hay
cultura deportiva
no hay cultura deportiva
y porque se los digo yo llevo más de 12
años poniéndome aquí la bandera chilena
en el pecho 12 años en los que estuve a
cargo de la selección nacional como
capitán en la era donde tomás gonzález
fue finalista olímpico y he visto a
muchos jóvenes llegar a los programas de
selecciones con la maleta cargada de
sueños cargada de desafío y en búsqueda
de tremendos tremendos resultados que
ellos esperan o que han esperado lograr
durante toda su vida que han estado
ligado al deporte y que por ese motivo
eso esos resultados o esos sueños que
han tenido nos han dado
motivos por ejemplo como la lección hay
muchos deportistas ustedes no conocen y
que por lesión no pudieron seguir
adelante o también están
los que el futuro enseñado la
indisciplina hay deportistas que han
desperdiciado su carrera ya en callo lo
que todos los deportistas nosotros
creemos que donde no tenemos que llegar
que a la frustración
voy a hablar de cuando yo tenía 16 años
y tuvo que tomar la decisión de
dedicarme al deporte
recuerdo que estaba con mi madre y le
dije madre me quiero llevar al deporte
quiero hacer esto en mi vida y les juro
no fue fácil no fue fácil tomar la
edición porque
la crítica fue lo primero que apareció
no tan solo de la gente que nos rodeaba
sino que también de nuestros amigos de
nuestros familiares porque pongamos en
contexto un penquista con 16 años irse a
vivir a santiago solo sin estudiar hacer
deporte profesional con un poco in
sólido no algo que una vez solamente las
películas eso no pasa que en chile
pero es que los papás fueron un rol
fundamental a la hora de hablar de alto
rendimiento y a la hora de hablar de la
formación de un deportista
pero los padres también necesitan un
apoyo
los padres necesitan un apoyo
porque no es fácil enfrentarse a la poca
cultura deportiva de este país y yo lo
veo hoy en día como entrenador que tengo
que también educar a los padres para que
si esta cultura hoy es hoy entrenadora
de selección de menores de nuestro país
y me ha tocado enfrentar a padres y
apoderados que la verdad no tiene ni
idea de lo que están viendo sus hijos
pero volviendo al tema de mi madre
cuando ella le pregunto a mi familia y
le contó este anhelo y se enfrentó a
ellos
diciéndoles que yo me iba a ir a
santiago que creen ustedes que fue lo
que la familia les dijo
la verdad la familia no dijo mucho pero
dejó una duda de esa duda y esas
preguntas que me hacen aún más honda en
la tesis de que no hay cultura deporte
en nuestro país
la pregunta era y cómo lo hará cristian
para salir adelante si el deporte no te
da nada
salir adelante
en lo que nosotros llamamos alto
rendimiento prepararnos para la vida
prepararnos para la vida y entregarle a
todas las personas o niños que inicien
un proceso de erección distintas
herramientas que lo hagan avanzar en el
post deporte porque si bien el deporte
tiene que ver con obviamente tener
grandes resultados deportivos también
tiene que ver con preparar al hombre
para la vida y en ese contexto
tenemos por ejemplo con deportividad
buenas relaciones
relaciones con sus con sus más cercanos
con su familia con sus amigos el deporte
tiene que entender
que puede impactar tanto de manera
positiva como negativa en otra persona
el deportista tiene un rol muy
importante para la sociedad una vez un
gran entrenador me dijo que a mayor
éxito alcanzado de un deportista mayor
el compromiso que tiene que tener con la
sociedad el deporte también tiene que
sacar ese estigma que todos creemos que
los estudios no están ligados con el
deporte se mentira un deportista debe
estudiar debe tener hábitos de estudio
al menos
avanzar en una carrera deportiva quizás
no tener una carga académica igual como
la que tiene un estudiante normal que no
tiene siete horas de entrenamiento de
ellas pero tiene que avanzar en el
estudio recordemos que los estudios son
los que nos dan la herramienta posterior
al deporte
el trabajo o profesión tiene que ver con
que nosotros tenemos que trabajar muy
duro para lograr nuestro objetivo ya que
el trabajo va directamente relacionado
con la motivación saben por qué
porque si uno trabajo duro yo no avanza
y esto trasciende
si yo no avanzo como te motivas
es por eso el trabajo duro super
importante y nosotros los de murcia lo
conocemos sabemos lo que significa
trabajar duro y por último los
deportistas deben desarrollar distintos
tipos de habilidades habilidades
que te haga una mejor persona
habilidades que estén relacionadas con
el deporte como por ejemplo asistir a
las sesiones de kinesiología comer bien
alimentarse bien suplementar se
conocerse
escribir leer bailar
son distintas habilidades que nos van a
ayudar a desarrollarnos en muchas otras
cosas y otras facetas que no tan sólo
tengan que ver con el deporte y que nos
van a hacer seres mucho más íntegros y
sanos de cuerpo pero también de mente y
me voy a quedar en la mente porque la
mente para mí
es el factor fundamental que tiene que
tener un deportista a la hora de hablar
de alto rendimiento
el deportista no debe tener miedo
saben por qué
una vez un entrenador de un campeón
olímpico en una durante un circuito de
copas del mundo me dijo
el deporte
para las personas es más peligroso que
la guerra
cuando uno va a la guerra
si uno pierde simplemente te mueres
pero cuando no están en el deporte va a
competir y pierdes vives con esa
frustración el resto de tu vida
el resto de tu vida
pero para no vivir con esa frustración
uno tiene que tener una mente muy muy
muy trabajada desarrollar habilidades y
todo lo que te dé las herramientas para
poder entender de que tienes que tener
los pies los pies bien puestos en la
tierra para saber cuáles son los
resultados que tú estabas buscando
cuáles son los objetivos que va a buscar
y así nunca vas a estar
trabajando para algún alcanzable eso lo
que hace la diferencia entre alguien que
sabe para dónde va caminando y alguien
que anda en búsqueda de algo
inalcanzable
para poner esto en contexto
hablo de poner los pies de la tierra de
contextualizar lo que uno quiere y esto
trasciende más allá del deporte
obviamente recuerdo que cuando yo llegué
a santiago me topo con el entrenador
cubano que había en ese tiempo en la
selección y me dice
mira tú nunca va a ser campeón olímpico
tú nunca va a ser campeón mundial pero
si trabajas duro si estudias si
desarrollas tus habilidades
si haces lo que tienes que hacer con
mucha disciplina es muy probable que la
vida te premie
y sea campeón continental medallista en
un sudamericano en un panamericano o lo
mejor si trabaja mucho más duro todavía
y le mete mucho más cabeza puede llegar
a una final mundial
y eso en ese momento me dolió muchísimo
imagínense cuando uno llega al deporte y
cree está la selección está compitiendo
ya hoy por la media olímpica y no es así
no es así uno tiene que tener los pies
pues los pies bien puestos la tierra
contextualizarse saber para dónde va y
eso fue lo que me llevó a lograr los
resultados que tuve y eso es lo que me
llevó a hoy en día estar parado aquí ser
entrenador y plantearme objetivos
concretos
ahora les pregunto a ustedes
desarrollan su habilidad
cómo están las relaciones sociales de
ustedes
hace cuánto que no escriben una carta
no es lo mismo que una persona lea lo
que tú sientes que tú se lo digas porque
alguna me pueden decir no si yo siempre
le digo a mi pareja que lo quiero a mi
papá que la amo sí pero alguien dijo por
ahí que las palabras se las lleva el
viento
les quiero dar un ejercicio cuando
llegan a su casa escriban
escriban escriban sobre los cuatro
aspectos que hemos estado hablando y que
la hable en este momento escriban sobre
sus miedos escriban sobre lo que los
apasiona y en base a ello habrá un plan
de acción un plan de acción que cambie
su vida porque eso lo que marca la
diferencia entre una persona que se
levanta todos los días
a tomar el mismo café a comer el mismo
van a caer la rutina rutina que todos
nosotros y la mayoría de las personas a
gota
y que en el fondo siempre termina en
trastornos psicológicos depresiones
problemas de exceso rupturas familiares
y la verdad es que en el deporte
nosotros amamos la rutina la elegimos
nosotros queremos esa rutina porque
sabemos para dónde vamos porque sabemos
de qué manera tenemos que trabajar
nuestra rutina por lo tanto hagan el
ejercicio escriban anoten porque si
saben salir adelante sabrán también cómo
seguir adelante muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]